después de haber marchado por primera
vez en un Primero de Mayo juntos desde
el año 2009 los sindicatos franceses no
dan su brazo a torcer en su guerra en
contra de la Reforma de la jubilaciones
del gobierno de Manuel macron que
aumentó la edad de retiro de 62 a 64
años de edad tras la gran marcha de ayer
primero de mayo que según los sindicatos
reunió a dos coma tres millones de
personas una gran cantidad no tanto como
en enero pero muy importante de
manifestantes hoy se reunieron para
decidir una nueva fecha de manifestación
la número 14 será el 6 de junio dos días
antes de que la asamblea nacional
comience a discutir una iniciativa de
ley del grupo liud que es un grupo
formado por diputados de centro de
ultramar e independientes que buscan
derogar la reforma de la jubilaciones
concretamente el artículo siete que es
aquel que aumenta la edad de jubilación
a los 64 años recordemos que este grupo
fue el que presentó la moción de censura
en contra del gobierno de Elizabeth que
obtuvo más votos en la asamblea nacional
francesa estuvo a nueve votos de ser
aprobada tras la aprobación por decreto
de la Reforma de la jubilaciones por el
gobierno de Manuel macron pero comienza
a ver algunas divisiones en los
sindicatos del gobierno está diciendo
que los va a invitar a negociar a
dialogar sobre varios temas vinculados
al trabajo que serán parte de futuros
proyectos de ley o de reformas el
sindicato más conservador aquel que
siempre termina finalmente cediendo ante
los gobiernos cfdt ha dicho ya a través
de su líder que asistirá a estas
conversaciones la cgt es un sindicato
grande a la izquierda dice que todavía
se lo tiene que pensar que la respuesta
tiene que ser unida de todos los
sindicatos y sigue diciendo Además este
sindicato que su línea roja es que el
gobierno retire la reforma de la
jubilaciones para sentarse a dialogar